Thanks Dean. Throughout this lesson and others, Dean will give us more
advice and discuss the big picture when doing EDA. For now, let's
start by loading up some data. You can find a data file
in the instructor notes. This data file contains all the Facebook data
that we're going to be looking at. To load up the data, let's
first make sure that we're in the right directory. Here is my
current directory and I can see that I'm in a folder that
has the data sets. I can use the list.files command to figure
out what that files are within this directory and here is
the data set that I want. The pseudo_facebook data set. To read
in the data set I'm going to use the read.csv command. But
I need to be a little bit careful. I need to indicate
that the separator is really a tab. And that's because we're
working with a tab separated values file. Running the command, I can
see that I get my data set up in R. Now this
data set is similar to the kind that data scientists see from
time to time at Facebook. And it's especially the type
of data that they'll use when doing EDA. This file
has approximately 99,000 rows or observations in it with 15
variables. Each observation represents a user and that user will
have different information such as their age, their name or
their date of birth. We can see all these variables
by running the names command. Now in this entire process
our goal is to understand our user's behavior and their demographics.
We're going to want to understand what they're doing on Facebook
and what they use. This is why you see things
like friend_count, www_likes and mobile_likes. We created this data
set specifically for this course to have many features common
to such user level behavioral and demographic data. But
I need to say that this data isn't actual Facebook
data. So not all statistics in this data set
are going to be accurate representations of how people use Facebook
on a day to day basis. So our lawyers want me
to make the disclaimer that this isn't actual data from Facebook
users. But we did use a complex model to generate it,
and I think we can learn some very interesting things about it.